انتهت الضربات الجوية في الوقت الحالي ، وانتهت القذائف الصاروخية
، لكن في غزة لم ينتهِ ذلك أبدًا
محمود ، البالغ من العمر ستة عشر عامًا ، وهو يستطلع ما
كان حتى يوم السبت منزله ،
تشعر وكأنك لا تعيش هنا
منذ أكثر من  20 عامًا هذا الشريط الصغير
من الأرض الذي يقطنه مليوني شخص ،
عانى من جولة موت
ودمار إلى أخرى
في مدينة غزة ، مستشفى الشفاء ، تتعافى ميار شيخيان البالغة من العمر
10 سنوات من
إصابات بشظايا في كتفها في
الصدر والبطن التي أصيبت بها.  في طريقها
إلى متجر الزاوية
، أصيب ابن عمها حسام البالغ من العمر 11
عامًا أيضًا
، والدة ميار منى يائسة من
مستقبل الأطفال ، على
ما يبدو عندما أموت تقول إن
الأجيال من بعدي سترث
حروبًا أكبر وأكبر
في الغرفة التالية لمدة عامين-  يرقد بشير العجوز
شظية نائمة استقرت في رأسه
خارج المستشفى الحياة تستمر في
الأسواق
ويبدو أن غزة الصاخبة لديها قدرة لا تصدق
على استعادة الحرب بعد الحرب
ولكن كل واحدة من هذه الحروب تترك بعد
عالج عالمها النفسي أيوش سامور
الناس هنا لعقود من الزمان ،
ويسرد المشاكل التي تنتظر
الشباب والعمل بلا حياة ، والشعور بعدم وجود
غد يقول إنه كما لو كانوا في
طابور الإعدام ولا أمل ولا تفاؤل
يبلغ من العمر عشر سنوات  أتالا يحاول العثور على
مشترين لنععه ، لا حظ ،
نجا من الحرب ، نجا من السلام ، كل هذا
صراع
لا ينتهي أبدًا
بن ويدمان cnn مدينة غزة